hi i'm noah burrell i'm a phd student at
the university of michigan
advised by grant schnepeck and i'm here
to talk to you about our paper relaxing
common belief for social networks
so as a warm-up i'd like to introduce a
notion that's important in game theory
many of you might have seen this before
it's called common knowledge and we say
that a proposition is common knowledge
when everyone knows that it's true
everyone knows that everyone knows that
it's true everyone knows that everyone
knows that everyone knows that it's true
and so on ad infinitum
so common knowledge is important because
common knowledge undergirds strategic
coordination
and by strategic here i mean in the game
theoretic sense
and often in game theory we'll assume
that agents
have common knowledge of some
proposition and that undergirds their
ability
to coordinate on something so for
example in the standard setting of game
theory we usually assume
that agents have common knowledge of the
payoffs of the game and
of the rationality of the other agents
and
this undergirds their ability to
coordinate on equilibria
now a more applied version of common
knowledge was explored by michael chen
in 1999 and 2000 in the setting of
network or gold games
so the model is that agents on a network
will decide whether or not to
participate in a revolt
and the way that they'll make this
decision is based on a threshold or they
will revolt if they know that enough of
their age
neighbors will revolt uh but they won't
revolt if they don't know that
so we can go through a quick example
here we have uh
four agents represented by the vertices
of this graph and the numbers inside
each vertex represent the thresholds of
the agents
uh so the key thing we'll look at is the
dotted line in the middle and we'll say
first we'll consider that the dotted
line is present in the graph along with
all the other edges
and then we'll consider what happens if
the dotted line is not present in the
graph but all the other edges are
so first if we include the dotted line
then
every agent uh who can observe
the thresholds of their neighbors
according to the graph
will be able to observe the thresholds
of every other agent
and they'll also be able to observe that
every other agent can observe every
other agent
and therefore they will all know
that if they all revolt together as a
group before then
everyone's threshold will be met and so
that revolt is sustainable
and so that revolt is supported in an
equilibrium now if we remove
the dotted line then the agents on the
left and the right whose threshold is
equal to three
can't see each other and therefore they
don't know
whether or not the thresholds of the
agents whose threshold is four
on the top and the bottom are satisfied
because for example
uh the agent that they cannot observe
the threshold of
might have a threshold of five so even
if all four agents were bolted together
they wouldn't be satisfied and so such
an agent would not participate in a
revolt
further the agents with threshold 4 who
can see
the thresholds of every agent in the
graph will also be able to see
that the agents with threshold three
can't observe each other
and they'll be able to recreate this
reasoning and they will also decide not
to revolt so
by adding the edge we'll have all the
agents can revolt and if we remove the
edge then none of the agents would
revolve
now there's some important implications
of the model beyond just that example
uh the first is that certainty uh that
the agents require
implies that they need common knowledge
that the thresholds are met in order to
participate
in a revolt
and that becomes a strict requirement as
common knowledge is in midi settings
another important implication is that in
this model common knowledge becomes a
local phenomenon
so typically we think of common
knowledge as being something that's
shared among the entire population of
agents
but here we could imagine say our
example from the previous slide
was embedded in some larger graph and we
could apply a similar reasoning that
still if all those agents could observe
each other
they would have enough of the common
knowledge they would need
in that local setting uh to still
participate in the revolt
regardless of what was going on in the
larger graph
unfortunately uh the last implication is
limiting from a computational
perspective because
finding pockets of this local common
knowledge reduces defining cliques which
is computationally hard
now another uh work that followed up
on the initial work on common knowledge
was from monder and samut
and they defined a new notion of common
belief so we say a proposition is common
belief when everyone believes with
probability p
that it's true everyone believes the
probability p that everyone believes
with probability p
that it's true everyone believes with
probability p that everyone believes
with probability p
that everyone believes the probability p
that it's true and again so on ad
infinitum so what we've done here
is taken the definition of common
knowledge and replaced
the word nose with beliefs with
probability p
every place that it occurs and that's
how common belief
represents a relaxation of the notion of
common knowledge
and in fact common belief represents the
right notion
to relax common knowledge in many ways
so
although it's not the only proposed
method of relaxing the notion of common
knowledge
it turns out that when common belief
approximates common knowledge then
agents are able to approximately
coordinate
uh in the way that they would coordinate
exactly if they had common knowledge
and so we say common belief undergirds
approximate coordination
so both of these notions followed from
exploring sort of the consequences
of assuming common knowledge but they
both have
key limitations in the setting we're
interested in which is
applying uh and exploring ideas related
to common knowledge in social networks
and the limitation is that both
key ideas are not useful in many natural
graphs
so for example the local common
knowledge
uh will be limited even in an
erdos-renyi random graph with p
equals one-half because such a graph
will not have large cliques
but that's a setting where we'd expect
agents to be able to coordinate in a
large group
not just in the small cliques that would
be present because each agent has a lot
of information about the rest of the
network
they on average would see about half the
graph
on the other hand in a sparser graph
like an erdos-trendy random graph of p
equals 10 over n then population level
phenomenon like common belief
will not arise
so in this paper we propose to relax
common belief as the name implies
uh to a notion of factional belief that
allows us to
transcend those limitations so we say
that a proposition is factional belief
if there exists a faction of agents who
believe with probability p that it's
true
there exists a faction of agents who
believe with probability p that there
exists a fraction of agents who believe
the probability p
that it's true and again and so on add
infinitum
so what we've done here is replace the
everyone in the definition of common
belief
with uh there exists a faction at every
place that it occurs
and what we explore in the paper is the
idea that we would like factional belief
to undergird partial approximate
coordination or approximate coordination
among some faction
of agents much in the same way that
common belief undergirds approximate
coordination which again is analogous to
the way common knowledge undergirds
strategic coordination
so that exploration takes the form of
these four points that we label as our
contributions first of which is
formally defining a notion of factional
belief which can be used to analyze
revolt games on general graphs
then providing an algorithm that
characterizes a structural result about
the types of equilibria that are
possible in such games
showing that surprisingly it's
sufficient for our algorithm to only
have access to the degree sequence of
the network not the entire network
itself
and lastly applying our algorithms to
simulated network data to explore how
equilibrium revolt sizes vary with
underlying parameters of the network
and of the model
now we won't have time in this
presentation
to go through the formal definition of
our notion of factional belief
uh because it involves a sort of lengthy
setup
with respect to modeling knowledge and
belief in the game theoretic setting and
drawing an analogy with the definition
of common belief
but we can present an informal
definition here that will be good enough
to build the intuition for this talk
so we'll say a proposition is common p
new belief which is our notion of
factional belief
if there exists a mu fraction of agents
who believe with probability p
that it's true there exists a mu
fraction of agents who believe with
probability p
that there exists a mu fraction of
agents who believe with probability p
that it's true
and so on had infinite so here what
we've done is sort of
inserted a mu fraction of agents as
being
a more specific definition of what it
means to be a faction of agents
now this isn't the only definition that
might meet that criterion of what
constitutes a faction of agents and
we'll return to that briefly at the end
of the talk
but this definition uh when you go
through the formalities
retains the nice mathematical properties
of common belief
in the way that we intended and in
particular
like i said earlier what we'd like is
that factional belief undergirds prox
partial approximate coordination and
what we're able to do with our
definition of factional belief which is
common p new belief is show that commonp
new belief undergirds partial
approximate
coordination and network revolt games
and that's what we explore in the paper
so now that we've briefly touched on
factional belief and our notion of
factional belief
it's time to get into our network or
both game model so we have a graph
g which represents a social network and
the graph is common knowledge among the
agents
each agent has a type t
in one of three categories alpha nu
or chi where chi is a collection of chi
types indexed by j
and we'll get into the naming
conventions for these types on the next
slide
but for now i'd like to say that types
are assigned according to a state of the
world
s which is associated with the
probability distribution over the types
and that distribution for each state as
well as the distribution over the states
are common knowledge to the agents
and the gist of the way that the game
will be set up is that each agent will
commit an advance to a peer strategy
which maps each possible context where a
context is a key object in this paper
that contains uh the type of the agent
and the types of all their neighbors
in the graph a pure strategy maps a
context to an action
either revolt which we denote with r or
yield which we denote by y
now to return to the naming of the types
uh
intuitively we've set the game up and
you can see the formal definition in the
paper
but we set it up in a way so that
there's a natural strategy for each
agent based on the type and those
strategies give the agents
uh the names of the types
so we say agents of type alpha should
always revolt agents of type nu should
never revolt
and agents of type chi should
conditionally revolt and specifically
what that means on the last one is that
each type kai
j is associated with a threshold pair pj
muj
which means that an agent of type kai j
should revolt when she believes with
probability at least pj
that at least a mu j fraction of agents
will revolve
so given that setup the game proceeds as
follows first the agents commit to a
strategy
then nature determines the state and
agents are assigned types independently
at random according to the state
then agents observe their context and
apply their strategy to choose an action
so the solution concept we're interested
in is an
equilibrium and we say that in
equilibrium agents each maximize their
ex-ante expected payoff given the
strategies of the other agents
now for this work we're primarily
interested in finding the largest revolt
supported in any equilibrium and such
revolts are supported by symmetric
equilibria
in which each agent adopts the same
strategy and in particular the strategy
that they adopt
are the natural strategies that we
described on the previous slide
so it's helpful to illustrate the model
with a motivating example so suppose
that g
is a grid of n agents embedded on a
taurus where each agent has exactly four
neighbors and there's no boundary
now here we can say there are only two
types of agents the new type
agents whose natural strategy is to
never revolt
and the chi type agents whose natural
strategy is to conditionally revolt
according to the threshold where p
equals two-fifths and mu equals one-half
we'll say there are two equally likely
states a the anti-government state
where agents of type chi are more likely
and b a pro-government state where
agents of type chi are less likely
and lastly i'll introduce a definition
that we'll motivate later
and we'll say that candidate agents are
agents of type chi
with at least two kai type neighbors
now in the paper we're able to work
through the example which leads us to
the following proposition
which is that when g is sufficiently
large the event that at least half of
the agents are candidate agents is
common two-fifths one-half belief
that supports a revolt of size one-half
whenever it occurs
uh which helps us build intuition
for y common two fifths one half belief
undergirds a revolt of size one half
now we don't have time to work through
all the details of that example here
uh but we can go through the intuition
so the intuition is that
reasoning about the state serves as a
proxy for reasoning about the size of
the revolt
because the agents don't have any
information about the types of agents
outside of their contexts
beyond the what they believe to be the
state
so in particular agents can use their
context and the prior
to compute the probability that the
state equals a given their context
agents that assign a sufficiently high
probability to state a are candidates
for wanting to revolt
because there are lots of type thai
agents
given that the state is a most likely
and there is unlikely to be very many
type chi agents when the state is b so
that's where we come up with the term
candidate agents
now whether or not candidate agents will
want to revolt even though they're
candidates to revolt no matter what
it depends on how likely it is that the
number of candidate agents will differ
significantly from its expectation
and that leads us to our key challenge
which is that the contexts are
correlated so we can't apply a standard
turn off type down that we'd like to
uh to say that the number of candidate
agents won't differ significantly from
its expectation
with high probability
so here's an illustration of why the
contexts are correlated you can see that
these four chi type agents on the grid
all share one neighbor who i denoted as
a new type agent
in the middle and therefore the status
of whether or not each of those chi type
agents as a candidate
is not independent because their
contexts are not independent
so given the intuition that we were able
to build in the motivating example
the next step is to see how general can
we make the setting
such that our intuition still holds uh
and that
takes up a major portion of the work
that we do in the paper so here we move
into an algorithmic perspective
where we generalize the setting so now
we can return to the concept of three
types of agents the new types the alpha
types and the chi types
with a threshold pair p and mu so we
won't give them a specific threshold
pair now
we'll have more general p and mu we'll
keep the notion that there are two
states
and a distribution over the states and
we'll say a
is the anti-government state and b is
the pro-government state both with their
associated distribution over types
and uh to be a little bit imprecise in
the presentation
we'll say that these labels will assume
that the states are labeled correctly
and that corresponds to the notion that
the the size of the revolt
should be bigger in state a than it
would be in state b
because state a is the anti-government
state
now the agents will have a common prior
p which contains
uh p and mu the parameters of the chi
type agents as well as all the
distributions
and a natural algorithmic question to
ask is given values q star and mu star
is it feasible to efficiently determine
whether a revolt of size mu star is
supported with probability at least q
star
so we can conceptualize that problem as
a sort of standard decision problem
that we call revolt that i've written on
the slide here
and it turns out we won't be able to
solve this problem exactly
as we show in the paper revolt is
np-hard
but we can relax it to a more tractable
problem
in order to do that we'll introduce two
error terms epsilon and delta greater
than zero which will be given constants
and two additional priors p minus which
has p minus delta and mu minus epsilon
and all the distributions
and p plus which has p plus delta and mu
plus epsilon with all distributions
with those definitions we can now
introduce the problem promise revolt
uh which has a graph g
the prior p a value mu star and then
error terms epsilon and delta given as
input
and then the promise of promise revolt
is that
exactly one of the three cases which
correspond to the three output symbols
is true and given that promise
the task is to output the one case that
is true
so we have the three cases omega which
says that a revolt of size mu star minus
epsilon is supported with probability q
star at least one minus delta under the
prior p minus
a which says a revolt of size mu star is
supported with probability
q star within delta of the probability
the state equals a under the prior p
and empty set which is states a revolt
of size mu star plus epsilon is
supported with probability q star
at most delta under the prior p plus
so i think it's helpful to understand
these three cases
with this illustration shown on the
slide
and the idea is that given some u star
a revolt of size at least mu star is
either
very likely to occur in both states of
the world
uh which is denoted by case omega
or it's very likely to occur in state a
but unlikely to occur in state b
which is denoted by case a and lastly
it could be unlikely to occur in either
state
which is denoted by a case empty set
and as you can see in the figure there's
sort of fuzzy boundary regions between
the cases
uh where more than one of the cases
might be true
uh but remember that we are promised
that exactly one of the cases is true
uh and so we only have to output that
one symbol
now briefly to return to our idea of
factional belief from the beginning of
the talk
uh the way to relate revolt and promise
revolt to factional belief
is is the idea we saw in the motivating
example which is that commonp
new belief undergirds revolts involving
high type agents
so it's a little bit more complicated
than it is in the motivating example
because of the presence of the alpha
type agents but it's the same principle
okay so now that we've set up the main
ideas we can go
over a brief summary of our results and
first
the theorem shown on the slide is our
main technical result
which says that we can solve promise
revolt in polynomial time
when the largest degree of any vertex is
limited
and where delta is equal to delta n
which is a function that quickly goes to
zero so as the graph grows
the error term with respect to the
probability of
the revolt occurring
goes to zero quickly
and a surprising corollary to our
analysis to prove this theorem is that
to compute promise revolt in polynomial
time
we only require the degree sequence of
the graph g
uh not the actual network structure of
the graph
in the sense of which vertices are
connected to which other vertices
just what is the degree of each vertex
and lastly we're able to use our
intuition like i said that we built in
the motivating example and applied to
our
uh fundamental case we can actually
extend that intuition a bit further into
some important extensions of the
fundamental case
uh the most important is that we're able
to extend our result to general graphs
so you'll recall in our theorem
we limited the maximum degree of any
vertex
with some more careful analysis we're
able to get rid of that limitation
we can also consider the smallest
supported revolt in any equilibrium
whereas typically we're concerned
finding the largest supported revolt
and lastly we can extend the set of
states to be larger than just state a
and state b that we have in the
fundamental case
now for future work uh the main
direction for future work that we're
excited about is to apply factional
belief as a tool to understand
strategic coordination and cooperation
especially in network settings
and the most obvious place that this
might apply is
in uh relation to social norms in social
networks
because social norms naturally have this
recursive reasoning that's very
reminiscent of common knowledge common
belief and factional belief
uh where when i'm thinking about norms
i'm thinking about
what my friends think about me uh which
is exactly sort of the sort of recursive
rationality uh that that relates to
those concepts
there are also some technical open
questions that we left open
uh one of which is is it possible to
to describe an event or some sort of
practical event
uh that is common p new belief but which
the infinite hierarchy
refers to a different mu fraction of
agents at some step in the hierarchy
so the definition doesn't obviously
require that
each mu fraction of agents at each step
in the hierarchy is the same new
fraction of agents
but it's not clear whether that should
always be the case
uh in a more practical sense
and also as i mentioned earlier when i
introduced the notion of factional
belief
the idea of some new fraction of agents
isn't necessarily the only definition of
a faction
that might apply so there's a question
of whether or not we can use a more
general definition of fractional belief
where we're still able to keep the nice
mathematical properties of common p
new belief but maybe apply it to a more
diverse class of agents and
more sophisticated settings
so lastly i'd like to point you to
the full version of the paper which is
available on archive where you can find
all the details that we had to skip over
in this talk
and thank you for watching